on est jumelée c'est marrant parce que
quand lyonnais ont maintenant un petit
jeu égal et les dalton regardez regardez
attendent éclipse on le voit on le voit
pas non mais tous
[Applaudissements]
comme eric je me suis dit m 120 kg je ne
sais pas je ne connais pas que
malheureusement il n'avait perdu l'an
dernier des mais si tu es grand beaucoup
plus que moi je n'ai pas peur c'est
libre il m'avait perdu l'an dernier à
chaque fois c'est des mômes qui gagne et
j'en ai un peu marre et c est beau de
plus vraiment je n arrête de te frotter
très bizarrement peu sur mon dos et en
plus je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
quand il se frotte ça lui fait
d'électricité statut dans ses choix mais
j'ai en tout cas ils ont le mérite de
changer des choses
alors on est à genève
j'étais
[Musique]
c'est n'importe quoi c'est comme un fou
et mes missions surtout je suis méchant
c'est donc justement michel sera notre
invité cette semaine j'ai envie de le
connaître et de ne pas me voir et sur
l'interview quand il y aura donc j'ai
deux trois questions à vous poser sio
sur lui par exemple si vous deviez le
décrire c'est un homme de coeur et c'est
un sacré coquin
non chers ou fouet qu'elle allait faire
plaisir limite mais je ne passerai avec
un jeu ne contrôle aucun des vainqueurs
d'accord j'ai deux enfants à bazas a
fait quatre ans j'ai pas dormi
alors tout ce qui sort là tu peux tu
peux compter sur moi moins bien on a
bien grandi quel est l'avantagé de
bosser à vivement dimanche
bah c'est quoi c'est que yann truc hyper
important c'est que quand les fans de
vivement dimanche je te reconnais et je
les évite était juste à marcher vite là
c'est pas méchant
l'appareil celle invités --il dernière
quel tour de magie cartonne le plus dans
vivement dimanche
c'est la disparition parce que d'une
semaine à l'autre à peu près la moitié
du public c'est ton émission c'est ta
chance et tu ton émission cyril non tu
es pas très grand mais je t'aime
beaucoup ok je ne sais pas si tu es
petit tu sais très très grand mais tu es
très mignon je veux pas qu'on échange
les vestes le micro le métro n'importe
quoi
eux c'est la première émission on
échange des baisses qui est une musique
sans rigoler
[Musique]
ça vous plaît mais un micro quelques
pompes
il est dans ton slip on a deux fils
stephan eicher est avec nous
[Musique]
merci je te fais alors qu'est ce que tu
veux tu veux des nappes tu veux quoi
qu'est-ce que je te fais à toi un
d'accord alors lui en fait il n'est pas
du tout agissons il fat est l'un des
avions également juste à côté
donc merci d'être là merci bébé ne c'est
pas grave voilà allez tu l'a pas volée
sexuelle on y va je sais pas